Um, this is what I've been calling my new mom uniform.
I got it from the TikTok shop, obviously.
The link is right here if you wanna buy it.
I love it. Also,
I accidentally bought two,
so I'm gonna be giving one away.
Um, so if you're not following me now,
follow me. I will.
I will have another TikTok saying how many give it away?
Cause I bought it.
I bought it with my money.
This isn't like sponsored. I love it.
I just like.
I loved it so much,
I accidentally put it in my cart twice.
I was really stupid. So it.
I have a large.
This is a size large.
It's got plenty of everything that you need.
Nice and stretchy.
So, yeah, I got another TikTok shop if you wanna buy one.
The link is here if you want to follow me.
I'll be giving one away soon.
A size large,
so stay tuned.